That's a great question. So what do data scientists do?
I think it's it's really hard to to pinpoint exactly
what they do because it's going to be tailored to
their actual application area that they work. But in general, what
they do is they take data and they find meaning
in the data. And what the meaning is going to be
really geared towards is going to be the, the case
for what they would like to explain. So it could be
that a particular company, if they are looking
at a company or, or the project. If they
are looking for some, some particular signal or
something. I think in general in my mind what
data science does is, is use is use this data. Data sciences uses data
to essentially explain and perhaps predict behavior
be it human behavior or even like, like, behavior of of of a more
machine generated system, anything could be like that.